D can I play a favorite game with you
called the final five can I just talk
about how comforting this dog is me
right now I mean being here with the two
of you and having this dog to pet it's a
dream that you know we all people must
feel instantly at ease just having this
creature by the way this is the only man
in my bed this is a great man to have in
your bed he's been in there for 14 years
oh my gosh okay it's the final five oh
great
okay if it's a Ley family party who's
getting the
wildest I'm going to go I don't want to
say wildest but I will say my mom is the
funniest one in my family so I think she
can hold a room the best so I would go
with my mom well I'm in love with her
now so okay number two how much money
would it take to completely wax off your
eyebrows that's a really great question
um like a lot a lot okay good perfect
uhuh okay number three what's the
weirdest rumor you've ever heard about
yourself I'm going through a bit of a
crisis actually in this moment because I
don't think I've heard a rumor about
myself and I think that's quite
boring has anyone heard do you want to
start one oh God it's like crickets out
there people like nope you're good
you're nice and safe I don't start yeah
let's start one um that um uhhuh see we
can't even come up with one I need to
shave my eyebrows I think is what has to
I think I think we you should come back
and we'll do a stripe yeah okay uhuh the
best piece of advice you've ever
received hard to funnel down but one
that comes to the top of your
head well it's a my mom would always
again this is like mother Fountain of of
wisdom this works it works and it also
is like sometimes I just need you to say
everything's going to be fine but it's
always see your place in whatever
conflict you have and it doesn't just
apply to like interpersonal stuff it
applies to business it applies to
anything and sometimes you've done
nothing wrong and that's the takeaway
I've done nothing wrong in this
situation it's all on them and we'll
deal with it that way but if you don't
cross check yourself in part of
whatever conflict whatever it is is
happening then you're missing out on
like a really key part of conflict
resolution I think okay so what is the
first thing on your bucket list for 2024
I want to get back to
Tokyo I love Tokyo I love Tokyo so much
I used to go twice a year it was it's my
favorite city in the world and then the
pandemic hit and I haven't been back and
I'm going to go I think in March I told
myself I'm taking a break I we yes
everybody are yes I know and I I'm tired
I work I know I know I evaluate my life
all the time sometimes it's good to just
say like I'm going to take a this period
of time to to recalibrate everything I'm
in love with you that's all I need to
say oh thank for having me oh my God
this is so great good grief is scaming
now on Netflix it is so fantastic it'll
just enhance your life in every way
possible thank you so much you for be
right back